when i when i get emails from people who
are psychologically destabilized by my
argument that free will doesn't exist
these are people who feel like something
integral to their psychological life and
well-being
is being put in jeopardy
this is a video with a provocative
titling but i believe
appropriately so this academic charlatan
sam harris
has been left unchallenged for too long
he's been left unchallenged
to hold a set of contradictory beliefs
and use arguments which are completely
at odds with his own world views
against religion and religious people
and what does this person believe and
what am i really getting at i'm talking
about the fact
that this individual he wrote a book
called free will
and really in this book he makes his
case that
he believes we don't have any free will
human beings don't have any free will
and he's basically making the
determinist
case the hard determinist case so he
believes that basically
antecedent events or an uninterrupted
causal chain
is what dictates what we do and there is
no scope in that formulation
for any kind of free will whether it's
libertarian free will
or a compatibilistic free will now
i'm not going to go into a discussion
this video is not about
the schools of thought and philosophy
and what the
advantages and disadvantages of each
position the weakness strengths and
weakness of each position are this is
not what this video is about
in fact what this video is about is one
important fact
if you believe that you have
no free will then you are not
responsible for what you do
it's as simple as that morality all of
morality
is predicated on the assumption that we
have free will if you don't have free
will
i am not responsible for what i do and
so a pedophile with all due respect
not only in what they think not only in
what they
reflect on but in what they
do actually is it them doing it or are
they
in the words the famous words of the
charlatan
sam harris the academic charlatan
they are biochemical puppets he uses
this term in his book
in his little booklet that he wrote
if they're biochemical puppets so in
that case they're not responsible for
what they do
on what basis is it the case then on
what basis
is it the case then that you can point
your
scrawny finger at religion how dare you
how dare you argue on consequentialist
grounds
grounds or otherwise
how dare that we should be this or do
that on
welfare is x or this is nonsense and you
know it's nonsense and not only do you
know it's nonsense
not only do you know sam harris that
it's nonsense but so do your friends
your confidants your companions
colleagues in the new atheist movement
like daniel dennett
who refuted you and
i may read actually what he said in the
conclusion of one of his refutations
against you
this is what he said
he said he's talking he gave an analogy
of
playing football soccer or something
like this and he's saying
dirty fowling versus intentional fouling
versus accidental fan
and he says are these distinctions fair
justified
should harris be encouraged to argue
that there is no real difference between
the
dirty player and the rest of the the
rest
and besides the dirty player is
responsible for being a dirty player
this is
who is this is daniel dennett your own
friend and confidant
a philosopher who sees the
ridiculousness of the proposition
and he's showing you your hypocrisy just
look at this his upbringing
basically this is then it continues
everybody who plays games must recognize
that games without strictly enforced
rules are not worth playing
and the rules that work best do not make
allowances for differences in heritage
training or innate skill
so it is in society generally this is
then it continues
we are all considered equal under the
law presumed to be responsible until and
until and unless we prove to to have
some definite defect or
infirmity that robs us of our free will
as ordinarily understood
meaning here what that if you don't have
such free will
then all of us become
non-responsible we're not responsible
for what we do
so why do you how dare you make moral
cases and arguments against religion
you are a hypocrite look at me you're a
hypocrite how dare you
and and your new atheist friends that
know the implications
of your heart determinist stance
they know the implications of that they
are telling you hold on
if you really want to go in this
direction these are the entitlements
and we had one of the boys that i
debated some time ago spent an
hour trying to tell me what bad things
i'd done
in a debate with him in which he was
humiliated
in front of millions of people worldwide
millions of people worldwide
on what basis do you do you point the
finger of moral responsibility at me
when on your world view everything i do
everything i do is just
a product a net sum
of antecedent events in the past or an
uninterrupted causal chain
hard determinists have no moral case to
make
because morality for them is an
unfeasible concept
it's an illusory concept or indeed even
more than this
it's based on illusory assumptions and
presuppositions namely
at least a compatibilistic understanding
of free will thus
i say to you now you can't condemn
on moral grounds pedophiles and rapists
and you can't even say that they were
responsible for their actions
because in fact they were not
responsible for their actions they were
biochemical puppets
and what i find really most interesting
of all is that on his flimsy little
book that he wrote so-called book free
will
the man actually had the audacity to
write his name
sam harris at the bottom of it but it
wasn't sam harris that wrote that book
according to sam harris
but indeed it was the antecedent events
of the past and the uninterrupted causal
chain
that did so
these are the contradictions that you
must enjoy
and all those who follow you and have
this hard deterministic world
you must also endure i will say one last
thing
before i finish in fact i was watching a
debate between him and daniel dennett
where in which he actually said that he
receives emails
what people feel they have libertarian
free will
and when the emails come from them
saying that they have been
psychologically destabilized by his
worldview
and i want to end with this listen to me
carefully this man is going around like
some kind of atheist guru telling people
how to be spiritual
spiritual he is now you know going
around trying to
show people how they can be spiritual
and basically atheists at the same time
knowing
that this is what the human requirement
is
you know we have a tendency towards
these kinds of themes
psychological tendency but his friends
or the people that follow him
feel like his fatalistic lifestyle that
he's presenting for the people
is causing them destabilization
and this really shows you that not only
is your world view
is it inconsistent with the subsequent
moral claims that you make
but it's destroying the lives of the
people who follow you
psychologically and ironically from a
welfare perspective as well
so i say sam harris stop the shenanigans
you are a fraud and i don't want to hear
anything of a semblance
of a moral uh kind of
attack or interrogation that you may
bring to any religion ever again
was foreign